MAX SALTONSTALL: Hi.
I'm Max Saltonstall,
and I'm here
to show you Chronicle, Google's
cloud-native security analytics
platform.
Security systems
and their operators
are suffering from
intense data overload.
We see companies generating
petabytes of security data
to sift through, slowing
down the analysis
and making costs skyrocket.
Chronicle Security Analytics
solves these problems,
putting threat tools,
detection, intelligence,
and forensic signals into
one scalable tool set.
There are six things
that set Chronicle apart
from traditional security
incident and event management
products.
I'll walk you through
each one briefly.
Beyond just
ingesting and storing
all the data you throw
at it, Chronicle also
makes it useful automatically,
so you can easily
map people to hosts,
to IPs, and track down
the exact sequence of events
leading to an incident.
We get major benefits from
building on Google Search
components.
Chronicle is continuously
re-evaluating log activity
against threat intel.
When intel changes,
we automatically
reapply it against all
historical activity.
No other SIEM does this.
Five login failures
in two minutes
is no longer a
useful threat rule.
We extended YARA, an open
standard for malware rule
writing, to handle
event logs so that you
can write the types of rules to
detect subtle malware attacks.
Another perk of using Google
infrastructure is speed.
Even searches against
petabytes of data
take less than a second.
And because Chronicle is
a purpose-built security
application, clients
find that tier-1 analysts
are much more productive.
Most organizations
spend more time
managing and tuning their
SIEM than they do using it
for security operations.
With Chronicle, you don't
buy servers or storage,
and you don't tune anything.
Your team can work on
operations and analytics
and protect your business.
Get the benefit of
cloud operations
and get your analysts out of
the business of IT management.
Chronicle rewrites
the economics of SIEM.
We don't charge by the byte
or for ingest or for servers,
storage, or even compute.
You get a predictable
fixed price
based on the size of your
organization in people.
One simple price, all in.
And it won't break the
bank, because pricing
is based on heads not bytes.
We want to encourage you to
have as much data as possible
in Chronicle and never get
penalized because you've
gathered more logs to analyze.
How do we make all
that magic happen?
Let's take a look
at the architecture.
The data layer enables you
to send all your security
telemetry and
threat intelligence
into a private
container, where it
is augmented with additional
threat intelligence.
Within your private
cloud container,
your security telemetry
is normalized, enriched,
de-duplicated, and
linked together
into a coherent timeline for
analysis and investigation.
Finally, that data is exposed
via our investigation hunting
and detection capabilities,
as well as to other security
products, via APIs.
In addition to your
data, stored privately
in its own encrypted
instance, we
can bring in third-party signals
and curated internal data
to enhance your ability
to detect and respond
to threats quickly.
There are three ways customers
are using Chronicle today.
Extend your current SIEM
with high-volume data
that today you throw away.
For example at Google, we found
that DNS data is incredibly
useful for investigation
and detection,
but very few companies
actually capture it.
Almost no one keeps a
year of it in their SIEM.
But we keep all your security
telemetry for an entire year
and make it
instantly accessible.
Enhance your event detection
and response capabilities
by keeping the data for
more than a week or month.
EDR generates a ton of data,
and the vendors struggle as much
as customers to keep it.
We can keep a year of
it, make it searchable,
and correlate it
to other telemetry.
Evolve your old and rusty SIEMs.
They're overdue for an
update, and cloud technologies
can make them faster
and more efficient.
You can deploy Chronicle
in days rather than months
and transform your security
operations metrics.
Check out chronicle.security
to learn more about how
we can help you extend your
current security management
platform, enhance your
detection and response,
and evolve from
outdated systems.
[MUSIC FADING OUT]